now
[Applause]
you guys have a lot of very fabulous
famous followers and i was wondering do
you have any interest in sending a
message to any of them
yes okay great good thank you
um bill let's start with you uh would
you like to say anything to rihanna
riri
we
absolutely
love you
someone so talented so beautiful when we
heard that we couldn't our mouths
dropped i mean it
we we love you
she is the real deal
and someone else i admire to know and
just say will you say something to
little nas x
that young man wears me out he's really
amazing his what's inside his head
it's like i'd love to get in there and
see whoa how do you come up with this
stuff
you know so so thank you for the joy and
the drama and what might be coming out
with us following you soon too so
i want to see that
and it is amazing to watch an artist
develop right in front of your eyes okay
uh robert would you care to say anything
to oh oprah
what can you say about
a legend like her i followed her my
whole life and
she's such an intuitive and insightful
woman and i think we're all better for
her
mix
would you be kind enough to say
something to my friend kristen bell who
really helped bring us all together
christian um christian sorry
be good to dax
i love it they seem like such a fun
couple they just keep it real you know
but um it's thrifty week and we love
getting tips from our guests so if you
don't mind i would love to get a tip
from each of you uh that's a
money-saving tip bill well my
money-saving tip is i cook my breakfast
lunch and dinner
every day but i will every six months go
out and have a fine dining experience
and spend
150 bucks on dinner
god i would love a home cook bill meal
by the way um jesse what is your thrifty
tip
i'm a close-aholic
um
and what i do is i've learned that when
when i buy something
something has to go
so i don't shop
i've got too many clothes right now you
know and to sell so uh just be wise
about that there are so many people that
you can share what you have with don't
just throw them in the garbage
we've got all the homeless people that
need something
go out there and give you
give you give it yes absolutely
robert how about you
shop the dollar store for some food
items and
toiletries
i agree
i agree and mick what is your tip
well
[Laughter]
um
i do
shop the sales at uh
sax
[Laughter]
again so samantha um okay on social
media we love watching you interpret
slaying terms really you're the first
person that made me feel not alone in
the dm department um so
people also call it youth talk um so we
wanted to quiz you on a few terms today
all right
here we go all right bill we're going to
start with do you know what spill the
tea is
like spilling the beans
yes exactly
i've never heard the two equated they're
exactly the same yeah they are it's just
tea now it used to be beans yeah
we're moving up in the world though
um okay um thirst trap
as a family show
well i can say i'm always thirsty
oh
are you trapping bill
does anyone here know what a thirst trap
is
everybody knows okay by the way it's um
it's if you've posted a sexy picture on
social media
right meant to entice a follower okay
gucci oh good good good good she is it's
a high fashion label
well not apparently the kids are now
using it as we're all gucci we're all
good oh all right a lot of people know
this this is great okay this one i
didn't know at all snatched you looking
fine
apparently they say it about riri a lot
like she is so snatched
i totally went somewhere else with this
one
okay the definition is when a person's
hair and makeup and outfit looks
fabulous this one's my favorite i
learned about it on the show on our
drew's news chugi
that hasn't reached palm springs yet
by the way yes i love you um it means
something's uncool and outdated and so
over
that's so chewy
let me throw one at you okay
beat for the gods
i don't know it girl
what does it mean
it's like it's like you just be like
patti labelle just say that they beat my
face into place you're looking your best
it's like they don't beat you up like
your hair and your makeup and all your
stuff
[Applause]
see you guys have so much to teach us um
and something that i really loved
learning and doing some research about
you guys is how many
young
followers you have
that this is not
this is not just
it's a place of positivity
but you are leading a new generation and
that the predominant
amount of your followers are younger yes
that's our mission statement and they're
also
50 of them are women between 20 and 30
years old
i think that what you guys have put out
into the world is the spark that leads
to the igniting beautiful flame that
we're all moths to and i thank you so
much
for putting this out into the world it's
a game changer for people oh thank you
thank you thank you dude
my cheeks are sore from just grinning
it's just like
stop it
[Applause]
thank you so much for coming here you
have made our show so amazing it was
such a privilege oh be sure to follow
the old gays on social media tick tock
instagram they're everywhere if you're
not already on the feeder get on it
[Music]